au stade geoffroy-guichard à
saint-etienne
à la veille du derby contre lyon
l'entraînement bat son plein sous l'oeil
vigilant de robert herbin et le jeune
entraîneur stéphanois nous confie ses
impressions 1 48 heures du derby ce
match contre contre lyon s'annonce
extrêmement ouvert parce que les
derniers résultats que les deux équipes
viennent d'obtenir son très satisfaisant
bien sûr lyon à une contre-performance
ans en coupe d'europe
j'ai été surpris mais enfin sur
l'ensemble de sa saison en championnat
c'est une bonne équipe et comme
saint-etienne occupe aussi le haut du
tableau c'est un match assez ouvert et
certainement très passionnant le derby
bien sûr c'est un caractère assez
particulier
d'une part parce que les joueurs se
connaissent très bien ils ont l'occasion
de se rencontrer très souvent de
s'observer automatiquement les problèmes
sont beaucoup plus difficiles que dans
un match normal de championnat où les
adversaires on les joue qu'une ou deux
fois par saison donc les problèmes sont
sont beaucoup plus accentuée quand il
s'agit d'un derby
il ya aussi l'ambiance qui règne parce
qu'il ya tout de même une certaine
suprématie entre les lyonnais les
stéphanois les lyonnais pour l'instant
depuis deux ou trois ans ont pris
l'ascendant sur saint-etienne je
souhaite que cette année ce soit un
petit peu différent de toute façon je
crois que c'est un match qui s'annonce
extrêmement ouvert et probablement
passionnant parce que ce sont deux
équipes qui n'hésite pas à se livrer et
qui font tout pour essayer d'obtenir un
résultat favorable
preuve de l'attachement porté au club
stéphanois et de la place du football à
saint-etienne cette interview impromptue
avec des jeunes que pensez-vous du bout
du système du bonus va pour l'instant
dix ans un des trois ans quant aux
avantages pour nous parce que nice est à
égalité de points avec nous parce que
cette équipe a obtenu six bonus pour
faire pouvoir à la fin de la saison de
toute façon je ne crois pas que ce soit
vraiment une expérience très positive et
semble inciter certains certaines
équipes être plus offensive mai à
saint-etienne c'est toujours été le cas
enfin la toujours essayé de faire des
résultats et d'être une équipe essaie de
construire un beau football donc ça n'a
pas beaucoup d'influencé sur le
comportement de joueurs quels sont vos
rapports avec les joueurs exigeants avec
les joueurs et dirigeants mais je sais
qu'il soit le
proche possible d'en faire avec les
joueurs croient que on se connaît assez
bien j'ai une occasion de jouer
pratiquement tous les joueurs et puis
avec les dirigeants il n'y a aucun
problème parce que les dirigeants me
laisse travailler comme je le souhaite
et comme les joueurs savent que
finalement c'est avec le travail que
l'on arrive disons que l'esprit d'un
club est très satisfaisant d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui fait la force d'un club
d'avoir un bon esprit un climat de
confiance entre les joueurs l'entraîneur
et les dirigeants